اعلنت نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
استعاده قوتهم السيطره على بلده ريف نوبل
جنوبيس وتصديها لهجوم صاروخي استهدف مدينه
اوديسا جنوبيه البلاد بدوره افاد موقع
العسكري الروسي ان الدفاعات الجويه اسقطت
مسيره حاولت مهاجمه مستودع روسنيت النفطي
جنوب مقاطعه كورسك الحدوديه بينما افاد
رئيس الاداره العسكريه في خرسون ان الجيش
الروسيه استهدف المنطقه بذخيره حارقه
محظوره ما اسفر عن مقتل شخص وجرح سبعه
اخرين واندلاع حرائق في المدينه والبلدات
المحيطه بها
الى ذلك افاد موقع ريبار العسكري الروسي
بان وحدات اوكرانيه استطاعت الوصول الى
موطئ قدم عند الضفه اليسرى لنهر دنيبر في
مقاطعه خرسون ويتداول الناشطون صورا قيل
انها مسيره لمسيره او مسيره روسيه وثقتها
وتظهر اطلاق اليات روسيه النار بكثافه عند
شاطئ الضفه اليسرى من نهر دنيبر بالقرب من
جسري انتونوف وقد رفض المسؤول الاعلامي
للجيش الاوكراني في خرسون التعليق على هذا
التطور وقال ردا على سؤال للجزيره ان قرار
القوات الاوكرانيه بهذا الخصوص هو التزام
الصمت من جانبه نفى حاكم خرسون الموالي
لروسيا ان تكون القوات الاوكرانيه سيطرت
على الضفه اليسرى من النهر